I was told that you would call us
meeting for the first time in a bath yes
Selena Gomez and Jennifer Aniston's
friendship started in the John let's
rewind Jennifer Aniston filled in for
Ellen DeGeneres on Friday's show it is
so exciting to host a talk show for the
very first time and sat down with Selena
to talk about her new album rare blues
you to love me that's a very revealing
song I realized that everybody else
seemed to be narrating my life for me
yes so why don't I put something out
that is my side of the story
that's when Selena refreshed Jenn's
memory were calling their first run-in
ever well nobody knew who I was
okay ad you were in the bathroom wearing
a black dress okay and I meet her at
like a vanity fair' something event and
I was there with my mom and I walked
into the bathroom and I saw you and you
were just Thanks so nice you just like
walked out to the bathroom you're going
back and my heart like stops and I
freaked out and I ran to my mom and I
was like oh well that's not exactly the
glam Hollywood intro I would have
expected but I don't hate it
and just because they are friends today
doesn't mean Selena stopped being a
stand for Jen and friends what made me
so happy is like now now like people my
age and everyone else is just obsessed
and it just makes me so happy for you
and for the show because psychotic
and the love is mutual you've been so
sweet you oh you're you really are a
genuine fan and it's amazing and we
we've met we've known each other for
years you've been to my house we've had
pizza girl after my own part heart do we
love a pizza or what we love us we do oh
my god what I wouldn't give to get an
invite to a pizza night with Jen and
Selena that would be iconic so much fun
Selena dished about their surprising
friendship when et caught up with her in
2016 you and Jennifer Aniston's seemed
like really close buddies these days has
she given you any advice along the way
she's been such a an idol in my life
from as early as I can remember so it's
cool to be able to see how well she's
handled herself cute but Selena wasn't
the only guest to sit down with Jen on
Ellen Will Farrell got in on the fun to
answering some burning questions with da
Lister who was your first kiss with what
was her name it was o AB Abby get ya
down Gaby
mine was with a young man named
Christian what was your first celebrity
crush wound Oh Joanie unhappy day Sean
Cassidy oh yeah and since Ellen films on
the Warner Brothers lot the same place
where Jen used to film friends she
decided to pop by the old set and
surprise slash scare some fans who's
your favorite friend I would say Ross
no you're not dreaming who's your
favorite friend
you guys the look on that girl's face is
a legendary like is she okay do we need
to call for help anyway you can count on
et to bring you all the latest Selena
and Jen news so make sure to keep it
locked or right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stephens bye for now
[Music]